OK. So, tips for jogging.
So, these are some key tips you want to incorporate when you're starting a jogging program.
So, when you're out for a run,...
...you wanna pay attention to how you're using your overall body form.
So, when you're running...
...you wanna make sure that you're running and you have nice straight arms going.
You don't wanna have your arms going from side to side...
...because you become less efficient as a jogger...
...when you're running with your arms in this manner, OK?
And another thing that you want to pay attention to is...
...while you're running, you don't wanna be completely vertical like this.
What you want to do is have more of a slight lean forward with your waist.
So, another common mistake that many joggers make when they are out for a run is...
...they are sort of running in like an almost sitting motion...
...where this part of their body is in a downward motion like this.
And they are running, and they are just like that.
So, what I tell my clients when I see them running with that type of motion is to come up...
...instead of sitting and running in this motion.
What you wanna do is you wanna come up, have your slight lean,...
...make sure that your arms are in a nice straight motion.
OK. So, another key component for joggers is foot placement,...
...how you place your feet when you're running.
So, clients that I've had in the past...
...when they are running, their feet are sort of coming out to the side like this.
Ok.
So, instead of running with your feet going at this angle to the side,...
...what you want to do to be more efficient is make sure that your feet are nice and straight.